come on alright I think we all have a
lot to be thankful for this Thanksgiving
yeah I know I do I'm thankful to be able
to do my stuff here at PJTV yeah hey
don't go suing my ideas YouTube that's
what I'm thankful for I'm thankful to
live in this blessed country that we
live in amen to that
how can you say that this whole country
is founded on nothing but lies we have
to do this now yeah unless you don't
think genocide is important there we go
we premeditatedly exterminated the
entire race of Indian people I think of
being a Native American Native American
we came in here and we destroyed their
whole peaceful existence you might have
to have weapons before the white man it
couldn't have been the tribes fight with
each other
ya know so yeah so you know yeah it
couldn't be because of that okay because
war didn't exist until the white man
hang right white man screws up
everything and you too of all people
should back me up on that what and then
we deliberately gave them all these all
these germ-ridden things and Stockman
sucks just to try and wipe them out wait
wait a minute we gave them germ-ridden
things a century before we even had germ
theory biological warfare as we know
didn't even exist for another hundred
years man yeah and and the European
settlers just came in with diseases that
they never encountered before and so
they weren't immune not a wrong brah I'm
never wrong
Bills Bills never wrong yeah yeah you're
wrong okay
just like I bet you didn't even know how
advanced the Indians were learn it break
this to you okay but even this whole
Indian horse culture that the horse was
brought over with the Europeans yeah and
they didn't even use the wheel is that
all you care about is wheels can we just
have a nice day okay yeah I get it let's
just consume more right that's gonna
fill our void is becoming corporate
slave to this fascist system that's all
you are too it's there's nothing but a
slave excuse me I'm sorry but are you
out of your mind
if by out of my mind you mean crazy
enough to love then yeah yeah I'm crazy
enough to do that okay and if you guys
are saying then I want no part of sanity
okay because I don't want to be a part
of this system where all you guys do